herzlich willkommen und hallo zu ZDF
heute live an diesem Donnerstag an dem
es mal wieder ein Ukrain Update gibt und
in diesem ukrainerupdate wollen wir auf
das Ende Jahr zurückblicken gleichzeitig
aber auch voraus auf das neue Jahr mit
endet für die Ukraine ein Kriegsjahr das
geprägt war von einer Gegenoffensive die
weit hinter den Erwartungen
zurückgeblieben ist von Stagnation
von neuen Waffen die es aus dem Westen
gab ja und aber auch mal wieder mit
erheblichen Verlusten für beide Seiten
russland hat seine Wirtschaft
mittlerweile auf Kriegswirtschaft
umgestellt gibt laut Duma im neuen Jahr
eine Rekordsumme für Rüstung aus und die
Ukraine ist weiterhin auf den Westen
angewiesen und versucht händeringend
neue Soldaten zu gewinnen und zu
rekrutieren immer wieder zwischendrin
gelingen Achtungserfolge so wie zuletzt
über die Weihnachtsfeiertage hier sehen
wir
einer Zerstörung des russischen Schiffs
der Schwarzmeerflotte das ganze soll
sich zum zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag in
der Nacht ereignet haben die ukrainische
Luftwaffe hat das vermeldet es soll sich
laut Angaben um ein russisches
Landungsschiff im krimhafen feodossia
Handeln tja und das wird als großer
Erfolg als jüngster Erfolg von
ukrainischer Seite vermäet doch wie
steht es um das große Ganze was wird das
neue Jahr bringen und vor allem wie ist
aktuell die Lage bei den Soldaten in der
Ukraine die mitunter seit fast zwei
Jahren unermittlich und unermüdlich an
der Front kämpfen für die Ukraine
speziell zu letzterem Aspekt wollen wir
gleich mit unserer Reporterin Alisa jung
sprechen live in die Ukraine schalten
sie hat um die Weihnachtsfeiertage an
der Front Soldaten begleitet und konnte
die Stimmung erfragen ebenfalls heute
unser Gast ist exnatogeneral
Egon Rams sofern es von eurer Seite
wieder Fragen Meinungen Anregungen gibt
dann gerne wie immer über die
Kommentarspalten oder auch via Mail
zunächst zu unserem ersten Gast Egon
Rams General aD des heres der Bundeswehr
und
exnaten einige von euch kennen ihn
vielleicht schon er war öfters schon
hier bei ZDF heute live als
Militärexperte zu Gast Jonas Kapp stellt
ihn für uns noch einmal vor
Egon Rams war einer der ranghöchsten
deutschen natoosoldaten von 2007 bis
2010 leitete er das NATO Hauptquartier
in brunsum in den Niederlanden dort war
er unter anderem zuständig für die
Einsätze in Afghanistan
zuvor war er von 2004 bis 2007 als
Generalleutnant im polnischen stätin
stationiert in den 80er und 90er Jahren
hatte er verschiedene Positionen im
Verteidigungsministerium inne Rams ist
Träger mehrerer deutscher und
internationaler Verdienstorden seit
Russland die Ukraine überfallen hat
analysiert Rams in verschiedenen Medien
die aktuelle
Kriegslage damit zu Ihnen Herr Rams
einen schönen guten Abend
einen schönen guten Abend Herr
burgermeister Herr Rams lassen Sie uns
zunächst auf die aktuellen Ereignisse
schauen die es über Weihnachten gab wir
haben gerade das Video schon gezeigt die
ukrainische Luftwaffe hat ein russisches
Landungsschiff zerstört Russland
bestätigte lediglich den Angriff die
Ukraine hat das Manöver als großen Kuh
bezeichnet wie lautet Ihre Einschätzung
wie groß war dieser
Kuh also wenn es den Ukrainern und das
nicht das erste Mal immer wieder gelingt
äh russische Schiffe in den Häfen auf
der Krim anzugreifen und auch zu
zerstören und ich erinnere dabei auch an
die moskv die ja vor gut anderthalb
Jahren durch die Ukraine versenkt worden
ist dann ist das schon ein Erfolg und
wir müssen das daran messen dass
Russland sich zu großen Teilen mit
seiner Flotte aus dem westlichen Teil
des Schwarzen Meeres zurückgezogen hat
mit der Zerstörung eines
landungsschiffes geht zwei Fähigkeiten
verloren a militärische Güter
entsprechend zu transportieren oder auch
irgendwo seelandungen durchzuführen was
die Russen ja offensichtlich zu Anfang
des Krieges in der Nähe von Odessa mal
vorgehabt haben das hat sich damit dann
endgültig zerschlagen mhm wir wollen auf
das endende Kriegsjahr heute
zurückblicken Herr Rams und seit dem
Herbst kann man sagen vor allem im Fokus
auch als Zentrum des Krieges kann man
sagen die Ost und Südukraine ähm vor
allem die Stadt avdevka seit dem Herbst
hart umkämpft vor ein paar Tagen gab es
dann die Meldung dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte die zerstörte Kleinstadt
Marinka aufgegeben haben wie prekär
schätzen sie aktuell Lage in der
Ostukraine
ein also in der Ostukraine sieht das so
aus dass die Russen ich sag mal über das
ganze zurückliegende die jah immer
wieder Verstärkung dorthinebracht haben
zeitweil ich hier und auch in anderen
Bereichen der Ukraine sogenannte
Elitetruppen beispielsweise
Luftlandetruppen und dergleichen
die Russen haben mit diesen Truppen den
Erfolg den man sich erhofft hatte
nämlich zumindest die obblasten lchansk
und Don komplett in die Hände zu
bekommen bisher nicht durchsetzen können
sondern die Ukrainer haben auch badwinka
sehr nachhaltig verteidigt sie achten
daruf dass die Verluste nicht so hoch
sind und es gibt die eine oder andere
Information darüber dass ich sage mal
ukrainische Soldaten in Zug
Kompaniestärke sich gegen Bataillon und
Regimenter zu wehrgesetzt haben das
zeigt so ein bisschen die Situation
trotzdem glaube ich dass der ukrainische
Generalstab richtig entscheidet wenn er
dann bestimmte Ortschaften aufgibt bevor
die eigenen Verluste zu groß werden so
ein bisschen prägend für die erste jah
Hälfte war ja die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive lange wurde spekuliert
dann irgendwann fand sie statt es ging
langsamer für die ukrainischen Truppen
voran als gedacht warum ist die
ukrainische Großoffensive die es dann so
im Frühjahr Sommer gab nicht so stark
angekommen wie man sich das erhofft oder
gedacht
hatte ich glaube dass das zwei Gründe
hat der eine Grund ist der dass die
Russen in diesen Bereichen sehr intensiv
verteidigungsstellen Stellungen in
mehreren Linien ausgebaut haben und das
ist in diesem Bereich sehr große
Minenfelder gegeben hat mit denen die
Ukraine offensichtlich nicht gerechnet
hat und wo es ausgesprochen schwierig
gewesen ist diese Minenfelder zu
durchdringen um auf die zweite oder
dritte stellungsreihe der russischen
Kräfte angreifen zu können ich sag mal
der Durchbruch den man sich
möglicherweise erhofft hat ist nirgendwo
passiert von daher ist das dann
irgendwann in vielen Bereichen zu
Stellungskriegen übergegangen die von
der Ukraine durchaus geschickt geführt
worden sind die aber die erwarteten
Erfolge nicht gebracht haben vielleicht
war auch der Begriff
Großoffensive etwas zu positiv angelegt
und von der Erwartungshaltung der
westlichen Seite inklusive westlicher
Militärs vielleicht etwas zu hoch
angesetzt worden
es gibt weitere Gründe dafür die Ukraine
hat ja keine eigene Waffenproduktion
auch wenn sich jetzt Rüstungsfirmen
aufbaut um selber Waffen in bestimmten
Bereichen bestimmten Systemen zu
produzieren heißt das immer noch nicht
dass diese Waffen sofort verfügbar sind
das ist der eine Teil dabei und der
zweite Teil den wir immer wieder in
Erinnerung rufen müssen ist die Tatsache
die ukreine ist in all diesen Fragen der
militärischen Hilfe vom Westen abhängig
das fängt mit der Munition an wo wie wir
ja alle wissen die Europäische Union
eine Million Schuss bis zum Ende diesen
Jahres zugesagt hatte und wo wir jetzt
irgendwo zwischen 300 und 400 000 liegen
mit der Lieferung und äh die Lieferung
von ich sage mal rund 600 000 Schuss
noch in den letzten drei Tagen diesen
Jahres dürfte ausgesprochen
unwahrscheinlich sein das heißt man
musste aufpassen was man verspricht und
was man hinter erhalten kann und man
sollte auch dann auch in der westlichen
Hemisphäre bei der Bevölkerung oder bei
den Militärs mit solchen Versprechung
keine falschen Erwartung wecken das ist
ein Problem die Ukraine ich hätte das
gerne gesehen wenn Sie mehr Erfolge
gehabt hätten und beispielsweise im
Süden Richtung militopol hätte
durchstoßen können es ist hier verwerrt
geblieben das heißt der Krieg zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine die Aggression
Russlands und die Verteidigung der
Ukraine geht in ein weiteres Jahr wir
bekommen erste Fragen unserer zuschau
zauerin und Zuschauer rein Herr Rams ich
stell gerne leite das gerne an Sie
weiter ein Zuschauer fragt was bringen
denn solche Offensive Offensive
Nadelstiche wie das jetzt jüngst über
Weihnachten der Fall war mit dem
Landungsschiff der Ukraine ohne
wirkliche
Großoffensive also ich glaube man kann
wirklich sagen dass jeder auch noch so
kleiner Erfolg eine Rolle spielt mit
Blick auf die Moral der ukrainischen
Soldaten und der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung und dass jeder nadelsticht
in die Ukraine den Russen setzt den
Russen auch weh tut
das gilt sowohl für Seestreitkräfte als
auch für Luftstreitkräfte es gibt ja
hier die Information dass drei relativ
moderne Jagdbomber der Russen in den
letzten Tagen von der Ukraine
abgeschossen worden sind das sind
Kleinigkeiten auf den Blick aber diese
Verluste summieren sich im Laufe der
Zeit auf und durch diese aufsumierung
verliert dann möglicherweise Russland in
bestimmten Bereichen ich sprach gerade
von dem westlichen Schwarzen Meer
bestimmte Fähigkeiten um diesen Krieg
erfolgreich WE weiterführen zu können es
wäre gut gewesen wenn die wenn es der
Ukraine mit einer Offensive gelungen
wäre beispielsweise über militopol bis
zum Asowschen Meer vorzustoßen um auf
diese Art und Weise die Krim
abzuschneiden denn das ist ein dann ein
Ereignis was möglicherweise auf vielen
kleinen Ereignissen berot dann aber auch
eine entsprechende Wirkung erreicht und
um diese Wirkung muss es gehen
beispielsweise auch um den Präsidenten
Putin vielleicht dann doch noch mal
davon zu überzeugen dass Verhandlung
vielleicht nicht so schlecht mhm wir
wollen ja heute gleichzeitig auch
vorausschauen auf das neue Jahr 2024 was
glauben sie wird es noch mal eine neue
Großoffensive der Ukraine alsbald geben
und falls ja wann wäre da ein günstiger
Zeitpunkt also her burürgermeister ich
habe nach wie vor keine Glaskugel von
daher mit aller Vorsicht und ohne zu
spekulieren ich gehe davon aus dass die
Ukraine neue Verbände aufstellen wird
oder die fahrenden Verbände entsprechend
auffrischen wird diese Verbände müssen
entsprechend ausgebildet werden äh dabei
unterstützten wir ja die Bundeswehr
bildet zum Ende bis zum Ende diesem
Jahres 10.000 ukrainische Soldaten aus
das ist auch eine Zahl die gehalten wird
die Ukraine braucht es weiterin
entsprechende Waffensysteme sie braucht
die Waffensysteme Stichwort
Luftüberlegenheit der Russen
insbesondere im Bereich der Flugabwehr
und der Luftverteidigung dort sind neue
Waffensysteme angekündigt und ich hoffe
dass diese Waffensysteme möglich schnell
kommen damit die Luftüberlegenheit der
Russen äh entsprechend abgebaut und
gemindert werden kann und die Ukraine
auch in diesem Bereich entsprechend
eigene Aktionen ergreifen kann und ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt ist der der Westen
muss liefern ob das den künftig die F16
Flugzeuge sind die möglicherweise mit
ersten Teilen im ersten Quartal
ausgeliefert werden die
Pilotenausbildung findet statt oder ob
das Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer und
artilleriesysteme und vor allen Dingen
auch Munition ich sprach die Munition ja
gerade schon mal an es ist ungeheuer
wichtig dass die Ukraine über die chende
Munition verfügt denn wir können immer
noch davon ausgehen dass die Russen
beispielsweise bei Artilleriefeuer etwa
die ich sage mal achtfache bis zehnfache
Menge an Munition pro Tag verfeuert die
die Ukraine einfach nicht hat und darauf
entsprechend adeäquat antworten zu
können Waffen Munition Material ist das
ein haben sie gerade angesprochen da
wollen wir auch gleich noch einmal
konkreter drauf schauen was das neue
Jahr da bringen könnte für die Ukraine
Mannstärke ist allerdings das andere
unser Zuschauer Alex fragt hat die
Ukraine überhaupt genug Männer um noch
zu
gewinnen also das diese Frage würde ich
eindeutig mit Ja beantworten die Ukraine
hat weniger deutlich weniger Verluste
als die russische Seite das ist eine
Feststellung die kann man aus
verschiedensten Nachrichtenquellen kann
man die belegen zweite Aussage die
Ukraine verfügt aufgrund ihrer
Einwohnerzahlen über hinreichen Männer
aber trotzdem müssen einem natürlich die
Aktivitäten die jetzt zum Teil begangen
werden nämlich dass man das
whpflichtigen Alter auf dem Bereich ich
sag mal von 18 bis 60 Jahren ausdehnt
oder 25 bis 60 Jahren ausdehnt das
bedeutet schon dass mehr Soldaten
gezogen werden können dazu kommt die
Maßnahme dass alle in dieser
Altersgruppe sich bei den entsprechenden
Behörden registrieren lassen müssen um
praktisch erfasst zu werden damit die
Ukraine selber weiß auf wen und auf wie
viele Soldaten sie zurückgreifen kann äh
das ist ein wichtiger ein wichtiger
Schritt der der Ukraine dann
möglicherweise auch weitere Kapazitäten
schafft von daher ich würde noch nicht
von Personal not reden aber richtig ist
dass Personal ein kritischer Faktor ist
der entsprechend von der Ukraine
behandelt und gehändelt werden muss um
die entsprechende Anzahl von Soldaten
zur Verfügung zu haben um gegen die
ständigen Verstärkung der russischen
Seite entsprechend erfolgreich kämpfen
zu können tja und wie es um das
ukrainische Personal aktuell steht wie
die Stimmung unter den Soldatinnen und
Soldaten in der Ukraine ist das wollen
wir jetzt uns mal ganz kurz anhören
danke schön Herr Rams bis hier hin wir
reden gleich weiter wollen vorher aber
live in die Ukraine schalten in denpro
steht meine Kollegin Alisa jung über
Weihnachten war sie an der Front mit
einzelnen Soldaten in Kontakt gekommen
unterwegs und hat die Stimmung mal
abfragen können Alisa einen schönen
guten Abend zu dir nach denpro wen hast
du wo getroffen und erzähl uns wie ist
aktuell die Stimmung bei den Soldaten in
der
Ukraine wir haben Soldaten sprechen
können in einem kleinen Dorf zwischen
Kramatorsk und kostian tinivka die dort
sich für ein paar Stunden um den um die
Weihnachtstage herum ausruhen konnten
und auch dort freiwillige getroffen
haben die ihnen Päckchen gebracht haben
ein bisschen Musik für Sie gemacht haben
um irgendwie einfach ein bisschen eine
Stimmung von Weihnachten dort rüber
bringen zu können allerdings in den
Gesprächen mit den Soldaten wurde ganz
schnell klar natürlich hat das eher
nicht funktioniert denn einfach den
Menschen dort den Soldaten den Männern
die kämpfen in dieser Einheit die wir
getroffen haben die sind seit fast zwei
Jahren jetzt schon im Kampf da gibt es
vielleicht mal ganz kurze
erholungsmomente muss man es aber nennen
aber es gibt keine wirklichen Pausen und
das wäre eben wichtig dass diese Männer
die dort an der Frontlinie kämpfen dass
die durch ein Rotationsprinzip auch mal
die Möglichkeit haben eben nicht die
ganze Zeit im direkten Feuer zu stehen
seit bald zwei Jahren das ist einfach
eine sehr sehr lange Zeit insofern waren
in den Gesprächen mit den Soldaten auch
viele Sätze sehr sehr bitter sehr sehr
enttäuscht also sind Sätze gefallen wie
während ihr ihr da draußen und damit
sind natürlich alle Menschen im Ausland
gemeint aber auch hier die Menschen in
der Ukraine die eben nicht an der
frontlin kämpfen während ihr da draußen
so erzählte mir der Soldat rumlauft und
lacht sagte er sterben wir hier und das
ist die bittere Realität für die
Soldaten dort und insofern ist auch die
Stimmung die dort jetzt eine andere also
die verändert sich einfach was jetzt
nicht heißt dass die Moral nachlässt
aber es geht einfach darum dass ja die
die dort kämpfen auch mal eine
Möglichkeit zum Durchatmen bekommen
müssen und das scheint eben sehr sehr
schwer zu sein das umzusetzen mm die die
Ukraine die Politik die ja schaut dann
auch aufs Neue Jahr natürlich auch nach
neuen Leuten es wird nach neuen Soldaten
gesucht Rekrutierung und werrpflicht
sind aktuell gerade ja große Schlagworte
und Stichworte in der Politik es wird
über Änderungen und Neuerungen
nachgedacht was hast du da Vorort aus
der Ukraine
gehört es geht ganz konkret um zwei
Gesetzesentwürfe die ins Parlament
eingebracht werden die Frage ist
natürlich wie wird über die abgestimmt
werden da auch natürlich noch Änderungen
vorgenommen Egon Rams hat es gerade
angesprochen general Egon Rams es geht
zum einen darum das wehrpflichtalter auf
25 von 27 herabzusetzen das wäre eine
Maßnahme über die diskutiert wird die
also vorliegt in diesem Gesetzesentwurf
Nummer zwei das hatte general Rams eben
gerade auch angedeutet was wäre noch
wichtig es geht darum in diesem zweiten
Gesetzesentwurf einen zentralen
wehrpflichtregister anzulegen in dem von
verschiedenen Behörden Daten erfasst
werden somit auch also alle Menschen
alle Männer erfasst werden die in dem
möglichen Alter dann sind um zu kämpfen
und wenn dort eben nicht die
entsprechenden Informationen einfließen
und auch herausgegeben werden dann
sollen Strafen drohen so wird es da im
Moment diskutiert was davon dann
tatsächlich umgesetzt werden kann das
ist die Frage es wird auch davon
gesprochen hier in der Ukraine dass die
tatsächliche Mobilisierung von Soldaten
auch die Ausbildung natürlich von neuen
Männern das dauert alles das braucht
Zeit bis zu drei Monate mindestens und
das ist dann natürlich auch noch eine
weitere Problematik selbst wenn so ein
Gesetz käme dauert es immer noch also
diese Männer Menschen fit hat für den
Kampf und bleibt ein Thema Rekrutierung
werpflicht dass die ukrainische
Regierung aktuell umtreibt auch der
ukrainische Armeechef Valeri salusni hat
sich jüngst dazu geäußert wir haben
Auszüge aus dem Interview mal
vorbereitet und können uns mal was er
dazu gesagt
hat was die örtlichen einberufungsämter
betrifft so bin ich ehrlich gesagt
derzeit mit der Arbeit D nicht
W ich mit der Arbeit D zufrieden wäre
würden wir diesen Gesetzesentwurf jetzt
nicht
diskutieren s wir wir freuen uns über
jeden Schritt der unseren Bedarf an
Leuten sichert wenn wir die Menschen
dank elektronischer Abrufe bekommen ist
das sehr gut wenn wir sie auf einem
anderen Weg bekommen dann auch aber die
Streitkräfte der Ukraine und der
Generalstab verhalten sich hier eher wie
[Musik]
Verbraucher ja also salni hätte nichts
gegen ein
werpflichtregister Alisa anfangs noch im
Februar 2022 als es losging mit dem
russischen Angriffskrieg da hatte man ja
wirklich den Eindruck dass es eine
unheimliche Euphorie und einen Willen
ernsthaften Willen bei vielen Männern
und Jungs in der Ukraine gab da wirklich
für das Land einzutreten und zu kämpfen
einige machen das jetzt hast du gerade
erzählt seit knapp 2 Jahren mit Blick
auf das neue Jahr 2024 was hast du
wahrgenommen wie denken Soldaten da
aktuell drüber und wie steht es
allgemein bei den Ukrainern um die
Euphorie noch für das Land zu
kämpfen sprechen wir zunächst einmal
darüber es gibt einfach Sorge natürlich
bei vielen Männern die jetzt noch nicht
an der Front kämpfen dass sie für diesen
Kampf Nummer eins entsprechend
ausgebildet wer und dann Nummer zwei
auch entsprechend eingesetzt werden und
es gibt die Sorge dass sie eben nicht
dann dort eingesetzt werden wo sie auch
ausgebildet worden sind und es gibt auch
Berichte von Soldaten an der Front daher
kommt nämlich diese Angst und Sorge die
genau das sagen die sagen ich bin
eigentlich für etwas anderes ausgebildet
worden und bin jetzt hier an der Front
plötzlich in eine Situation geraten für
die ich mich nicht ausgebildet fühle da
möchte die Ukraine ran an dieses Problem
hat also dort auch vor sogar mit
Headhunter Agenturen zu arbeiten die
also Nummer eins nach Menschen suchen
die mobil machen die also Menschen
rekrutieren wollen und Ihnen diese Angst
nehmen wollen die also Versprechen in
Gesprächen und dann auch in Trainings
dass die Männer sich mehr aussuchen
können mehr Wahl haben was für eine
Aufgabe sie übernehmen die auch ihren
Qualifikationen entspricht und da
erhofft man sich dass mit unter anderen
der Hilfe von so so diesen Headhunter
Agenturen man auch mehr Männer dann
überzeugen kann dann doch weiter zu
kämpfen und das wäre halt etwas was die
Soldaten dann entlastet es geht nicht
darum dass wird hier immer wieder betont
die jetzt kämpfenden aus dem zu
entlassen das könnte man sich nicht
leisten sondern es geht um zusätzliche
Männer ein Rotationsprinzip dass alle
genug Luft zum Atmen bekommen t das ist
auf alle Fälle ein Thema was auch unsere
Zuschauer interessiert m mercato
schreibt würde jeder Mann kämpfen hätte
die Ukraine in zi Monaten gewonnen ist
er sich sicher aber die Realität ist
dann doch etwas ernster und schaut
anders aus danke schön für diese
aktuellen Eindrücke aus denpro Diebe
grrüße zu dir
Alisa und damit zurück zu uns unser
Militärexperten Egon Rams der ebenfalls
uns zugeschaltet ist Herr Rams wir haben
schon ein bisschen vorausgeblickt auf
das neue Jahr 2024 und die Ukraine
braucht weiterhin Waffen vom Westen das
hatten sie auch gerade noch einmal
bekräftigt die Frage ist allerdings was
können wir speziell als Deutschland D
noch liefern denn gerade Deutschland ist
ja im kommenden Jahr in Litauen sehr
engagiert dabei an der NATO Ostgrenze
will man da eine ständige Brigade
stationieren da muss man ja dann schon
noch fragen was was geht was kann die
Bundesregierung da noch
liefern also was die Brigade in Litauen
angeht von der Deutschland in
überwiegenden Teil
stellt gucken wir nicht auf das Jahr
2024 sondern wir schauen auf das Jahr
205 26
folgende sie wissen dass diese Brigade
mit einer entsprechenden Infrastruktur
von Seiten der Litauer dort ausgestattet
werden soll um auch Familien und Kinder
mitzunehmen und das alles muss in den
Vorbereitungen entsprechend aufgebaut
werden die Infrastruktur muss gebaut
werden und von daher sage ich mal sehe
ich das nicht auf der aktuellen
Zeitachse
der heesinspekteur Alfons Mais hat sich
in den letzten Tagen geändert und er hat
geäußert und er hat seiner seiner Sorge
zum Ausdruck gebracht dass er gesagt hat
dass diese Brigade in Litauen
möglicherweise dem Heer in Deutschland
weh tun würde das ist der eine Teil
dabei der andere Teil ist der dass die
Bundeswehr nach wie vor bei etlichen
Waffensystemen Stichwort Kampfpanzer
aber auch bei anderen Waffensystemen
nicht über das Material verfügt welche
Sie nach Ihrem strukturbedarf haben
sollte und es wäre wichtig wenn man die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr
herstellen will in den nächsten Jahren
ich rede mal in Zeitraum bis
2027 und in einem zweiten Schritt bis
2031 dass die Bundeswehr dieses Material
bekommt dieses Material erhält dann mit
diesem Material auch entsprechend tätig
werden kann t ähm von daher das ist
keine unmittelbare Konkurrenz aber es
wirkt sich letztendlich auf die
heresplanung und die Einsatzbereitschaft
des gesamten Heeres in einer ähnlichen
Art und Weise aus ich lasse mich ein
anderes Beispiel nehmen ich nehme das
Beispiel flagpanzer Gepard wir haben
zuerst relativ kurze oder relativ
geringe Stückzahlen geliefert wir haben
mittlerweile größere Stückzahlen in die
ukreine gegeben WN mein kenntn Stand
richtig ist sind wir bei 40 gepah
mittlerweile und wir sind auch in der
Lage die Munition für den Gepard in
hinreichender Menge zu liefern durch
eine Produktionsstraße die von einer
deutschen Firma aufgebaut worden ist und
wir haben eine ähnliche Situation bei
Kampfpanzern Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 sind
strukturbedarf auch in den deutschen
Streitkräften aber wir haben ja der
Ukraine auch zugesagt nach einem
langwierigen schwierigen
Entscheidungsprozess im Anfang Februar
diesen Jahres ihr Kampfpanzer Leopard
1A5 zur Verfügung zu stellen von denen
sind nach kennisstand und Datum 22.12 30
bisher geliefert und 106 oder 105 stehen
noch in Deutschland auch die müssen
dahin denn ohne diese Waffensysteme wird
die Ukraine nicht in der Lage sein ich
sag das mal ein Übergewicht zu schaffen
auch nur ein lokales und örtliches
Übergewicht zu schaffen und dann
erfolgreich wieder in eine offensive
eintreten zu können
ich ziehe da einen Strich drunter
die westlichen Staaten haben bisher zu
wenig geliefert und sie haben sie oft
auch zu spät geliefert mhm schauen wir
uns mal dann die russis Seite an da hat
man jetzt auf Kriegswirtschaft
umgestellt und plant für 2024 mit ja
Rekordsummen für Rüstung im kommenden
Jahr laut Duma 6% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts
man spielt sowieso taktisch im Krieg auf
Zeit die Ukraine zerdrücken nennt es z.B
Militärexperte Gustav gressel was
glauben sie bleibt das auch für das
kommende Jahr die Strategie
Russlands also die Zeit spielt zur Zeit
für Russland und dann wird das auch
diese Strategie bleiben und es ist die
Frage ob es den Ukrainern gelingt mit
mehr Waffensystemen mit mehr Munition
diese Absicht der Russen entsprechend zu
durchbrechen und selber dann wieder in
eine offensive reinzukommen denn sonst
bleiben wir in dem Stellungskrieg wie
wir ihn weitgehend im jahrre 2023 erlebt
haben von daher es besteht die
Notwendigkeit die Ukraine in dieser
Richtung zu unterstützen und ihr zu
helfen um auf diese Art und Weise die
Ukraine wieder in Bewegung zu bringen
was die militärischen Kräfte angeht das
mich noch mal ein Satz zu dem Thema
Kriegswirtschaft sagen es hat auch
Abgeordnete Politiker bei uns in
Deutschland gegeben die Mitte des Jahres
von einer deutschen Kriegswirtschaft
gesprochen haben das wäre z.B eine
Möglichkeit um die Produktion von
Munition sei auf Kosten der EU
artilleriunition oder Deutschlands
entsprechend hochzusetzen wir sind
eingebunden in Tarife wir sind
eingebunden in Tarifverträge wir sind
eingebunden in die europäische
arbeitszeitverordnungen dergleichen mehr
das heißt selbst wenn eine Industrie
Unternehmen die Leitung eines
Unternehmens das will ist es dazu
aufgrund der Tarifverträge und der
europäischen Arbeitszeitverordnung nicht
in der Lage da muss man sich die Frage
stellen ob beispielsweise die Anwendung
einer Arbeitszeitverordnung auf
Streitkräfte der richtige Ansatz ist
oder ob man nicht auch andere
gesetzliche Grundlagen schaffen muss
damit die Industrie in einer solchen
Lage wie dieser wir befinden uns im
Frieden dann entsprechend kann die
Produktion hochzufahren und auch
entsprechend mehr zu produzieren wir
haben dafür z Zeit keine gesetzlichen
Grundlagen und wenn Politiker dieses
Thema anschneiden dann müssen sie auch
bereit sein einen entsprechenden
Gesetzgebungsprozess im Deutschen
Bundestag oder von Seiten der Regierung
her einzuleiten unser Zuschauer Stefan B
fragt auf YouTube wo liegen die größten
Schwächen von Russland und wie kann die
Ukraine diese am besten
nutzen also ich glaube dass die größten
Schwächen der russischen Seite die Moral
der russischen Soldaten ist und das ist
auch das pund mit dem die Ukraine noch
wern kann weil die Moral der
ukrainischen Soldaten auch nach 673 oder
75 Kriegstagen offensichtlich immer noch
sehr hoch ist
es gab kürzlich erste Meldungen dass
russische Soldaten die mit ihrem
Kommandeuren unmittelbaren aber auch
höheren Kommandeuren nicht zufrieden
waren sich ergeben haben und das zeugt
davon dass die Moral der russischen
Soldaten ich sag das mal vorsichtig eine
schlechte ist und dass aufgrund dieser
schlechten Moral dann auch die
Kampfleistung und die Kampf Kraft der
russischen Soldaten nicht so hoch ist
das heißt damit wo die Ukraine noch mit
arbeiten kann das sind ihre Soldaten mit
einer hohen Moralen hohen
Einsatzbereitschaft und der entsprechend
Unterstützung durch die Bevölkerung
vielleicht noch ein Hinweis von meiner
Seite es hat vor etwa vier bis 5 Wochen
eine Meinungsumfrage in der Ukraine
gegeben in der ganz deutlich zum
Ausdruck gekommen ist dass die
Zustimmung zu der Kriegführung und das
Nein sagen zu der Abtretung von Gebieten
an Russland irgendwo im Bereich zwischen
65 70% liegt von daher das ist ein Pfund
mit dem die ukrainische Regierung
wuchern kann und was man nutzen muss
wobei ich Frau jung vorhin in ihrem
Bericht recht gebe es ist für die
Soldaten schon hart wenn sie jetzt 670
oder 675 Tage mehr oder weniger an der
Front gestanden haben und vielleicht mal
ein paar Tage ausruhen in
Anführungszeichen zu Weihnachten oder
ähnlichen Anlässen haben das ist schon
ein schwieriges Unterfangen daher auch
da passt rein das was äh
gesagt hat äh mit dem Rotationsverfahren
dass er die die ich sag mal W
dienstfähigen und werrpflichtigen Männer
unter Kontrolle bekommt um auf diese Art
und Weise entsprechend
Personal auszutauschen damit diesen
Soldaten die so lange in Frontstellung
gelegen haben entsprechende ja Erholung
geboten werden kann mhm nun bleibt ä der
wichtigste Waffenlieferant äh für die
Ukraine im Westen vor allem die USA sie
waren es muss man sagen denn jetzt ganz
jüngst aktuell gab es ist vorerst die
letzte Militärhilfe aus den USA 2024
wird ein neuer Präsident gewählt und
sofern Donald Trump das Comeback
gelingen sollte stünde die Ukraine ja
vor enormen Herausforderungen das fragt
auch Annie Mac auf Youtube wie schätzen
Sie die Bereitschaft der USA ein weiter
massiv zu
unterstützen also was mich wundert im
Augenblick ist die Tatsache dass nicht
beim letzten Besuch von Präsident
selenski sondern beim vorletzten
letztendlich der gesamte Kongress das
heißt auch ein Großteil der Republikaner
dieser Unterstützung für die Ukraine
zugesagt hat und das geh's mehr oder
weniger aus innerparteilichen oder
innenpolitischen Gründen diese der
Beschluss weitere Mittel dafür
einzusetzen im Prinzip nicht gefällt
wird das heißt hier wird Innenpolitik
Stichwort Wahlkampf in den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika auf den Knochen der
Ukrainer betrieben das halte ich für
ausgesprochen schlecht und für
ausgesprochen schwierig für die
ukrainische Seite sie haben Recht die
die letzten Milliarden Dollar fließen
zur Zeit ab Richtung Ukraine und jetzt
bedarf es eines weiteren Beschlusses des
Kongresses und weitere Mittel sowohl für
die allgemeine finanzielle Unterstützung
als auch für die militärische
Unterstützung freizugeben ich bin davon
überzeugt dass der Präsident beiden
darum kämpfen wird
wie die Wahlen im November ausgehen
werden in USA da ma ich heute keine
Prognose drüber und ob Donald Trump
tatsächlich am 20 Januar des Jahres 2025
dann wieder ins Amt eingeführt wird ist
eine Frage die ist offen aber sie haben
recht mit der Aussage wenn das
tatsächlich passieren sollte dann ist
mit Blick des Verhältnisses der
Amerikaner zur NATO und wahrscheinlich
auch des Verhältnisses der Amerikaner
zur Ukraine eine sehr schwierige
Situation die dann auf uns zukommt ein
ganz kurzer und trockener Satz diese
Situation diese Schwierigkeiten müssten
dann durch die europäische Staaten
kompensiert werden und das wäre dann
eine echte Herausforderung wir dürf aber
nicht vergessen dass alle europäischen
Staaten oder Staaten der EU zusammen
oder europäischen natostaaten
letztendlich vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt
und ähnlichen Faktoren her dazu durchaus
in der Lage sein könnten das bedürfte
dann aber auch entsprechenden
politischen Willens und der
entsprechenden politischen Entscheidung
man kann nicht sagen die Ukraine darf
nicht verlieren und anschließend lässt
man sie am Hungertuch nagen dann ist das
ein Widerspruch in sich und zeigt zeugt
nicht von der Konsistenz der politischen
Entscheidung die wen haben das Brutto
inlandsbruck der einzelnen euländer
dieses Stichwort herrams schließt ganz
gut an die Frage an die Nobert Kranz uns
stellt warum liefern die anderen
europäischen Nationen Frankreich Italien
Spanien etc so
wenig also die Franzosen haben geliefert
die haben beispielsweise auch
marschfluchkörper geliefert ohne
Reichweitenbegrenzung und dergleichen
mehr Italien hat ebenfalls geliefert und
steht trotz seiner sag mal mit rechtsreg
ung die zurzeit haben durchaus nicht so
negativ da aber die Frage ist berechtigt
die Europäer müssten sich hier besser
zusammentun müssten besser koordinieren
da müsste man regeln wer liefert was und
das muss da auch tatsächlich
fließen
ja dann zu guter Letzt wenn wir jetzt
den Ausblick wagen
herrams frage ich ihn einfach der User
will anonym bleiben was wird
2424 bringen wird die Ukraine ihre
Anstrengungen dann eher defensiv
auslegen wenn es gerade auch ja
vielleicht weniger Waffen gibt oder es
sind die modernen Waffen das einzig
ausschlaggebende Argument für offensive
Operationen was glauben
Sie also die Waffen die Waffensysteme
ich spreche jetzt ganz bewusst von
Waffensystemen von F16 über kampfbranzer
bis zu atlerie und Flugabwehr spielen
eine sehr große Rolle aber ich hatte ja
vorhin schon mal gesagt das
entscheidende Fund mit dem die Ukraine
wuchern kann ist die Moral ihrer
Soldaten und ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass die gesamte ukrainische Bevölkerung
schlicht und einfach nicht in Russland
aufgehen will und dann möglicherweise
durch Deportation oder andere Maßnahmen
langsam aufgelöst wird wenn man die
Pressekonferenz nimmt die Putin vor 10
Tagen gehalten hat wo er seine
unveränderte Strategie noch mal wieder
verkündet hat dann kann man nur sagen
dort ist kein Lernprozess erkennbar das
heißt der Ukraine wird nichts anderes
übrig bleiben als sich mit Hilfe des
Westens entsprech weiter zu verteidigen
und wir im Westen alle westlichen
Staaten schließt die USA zumindest für
die Zeit noch mit ein müssen uns darüber
im Klaren sein dass letztendlich wir mit
unseren politischen Entscheidungen
Waffen und munitionslieferung darüber
entscheiden wie der Krieg in der Ukraine
weitergeht
äh vielleicht letzter Satz in dem
Zusammenhang von meiner Seite wenn Sie
keine weiteren Fragen haben wir müssen
uns darüber im Klaren sein dass die
Freiheit auch der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und der westlichen
Demokratien zur Zeit durch ukrainische
Soldaten und die ukrainische Bevölkerung
in der Ukraine verteidigt wird das ist
eine Tatsache und wenn wir nicht wollen
dass auf lange Sicht Putin seine Macht
versucht weiter auszudehen und seinem
Anspruch mit einem Krieg sein Land zu
vergrößern durchkommt dann müssen wir
der Ukraine helfen sonst kann es sein
dass uns das irgendwann mal auf unsere
eigenen Füße fällt und das wäre dann
erstens teurer zweitens blutiger und
wahrscheinlich auch für uns mit Blick
auf unseren freiheitwien Freiheitswillen
den wir ja alle haben kaum erträglich
sagt der exnateneral Egon Rams Herr Rams
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit heute abend
danke schön für das
Gespräch gerne gerne Herr
burürgermeister ich wünsche viel Erfolg
danke schön guten Rutsch für Sie und
auch für euch da draußen das war
zumindest für dieses Jahr unser vorerst
letztes Ukraine Update aber der Abend
hat gezeigt das Thema wird uns weiterhin
beschäftigen auch im nächsten Jahr es
bleibt sehr komplex und wir werden
natürlich auch 2024 hier regelmäßig über
den russischen Angriff Krieg in der
Ukraine berichten danke schön fürs
Interesse und für die Kommentare tschüss
und auf
Wiedersehen